now let's do a really interesting
problem so i have y equals x and y is
equal to x squared minus 2x right over
here and we're going to rotate the
region in between these two functions so
that's this region right over here and
we're not going to rotate it just around
the x x-axis we're going to rotate it
around the horizontal line y equals 4.
so we're going to rotate it around this
and if we do that we'll get a shape that
looks like this i drew it ahead of time
just so i could draw it nicely and as
you can see it looks like some type of a
i don't know a vase with a hole at the
bottom and so what we're going to do is
attempt to do this using i guess you
could call it the washer method which is
a variant of the disk method so let's
construct a washer
so let's look at a given x so let's say
an x right over here
so let's say that we're at an x right
over there and we're going to do is
we're going to rotate this region we're
going to give it some depth dx
dx so that is dx and we're going to
rotate this around the line y is equal
to four so if you were to visualize it
over here
you have some depth you have some depth
and when you rotate it around the inner
radius is going to look like the inner
radius of our washer is going to look
something like that
it looks something like that and then
the outer radius of our washer is going
to is going to contour around x squared
minus 2x so it's going to look
something
something my best attempt to draw it
it's going to look something like that
something like that
and of course our washer is going to
have some depth so let me draw the depth
so
it's going to have some depth dx so this
is my best attempt at drawing some of
that depth
so this is the depth of our washer and
then just to make the face of the washer
a little bit clearer let me do it in
this green color so the face of the
washer
is going to be all of this business
the all of this business
is going to be the face of our washer so
if we can figure out the volume of one
of these washers for given x and we just
have to sum up all of the washers for
all of the x's in our interval so let's
see if we can set up the integral and
maybe and then in the next video we will
just we'll just forge ahead and actually
evaluate the integral
so let's think about the volume of the
washer to think about the volume of the
watch we really just have to think about
the area of the face of the washer so
area
of face put face in quotes is going to
be equal to what
well it would be the area of the washer
if it wasn't a washer if it was just a
coin and then subtract out the area of
the part that you're cutting out so the
area of the of the washer if it didn't
have a hole in the middle would just be
pi
times the outer radius squared
outer
radius squared it would be pi times this
radius squared that we could call the
outer radius and if we since it's a
washer we need to subtract out the area
of this inner circle so minus pi
times inner radius
inner
inner radius
inner
radius squared so we generally just have
to figure out what the outer and inner
radius or radii i should say are
so let's think about it
so our outer radius
our outer
radius is going to be equal to what
well we can visualize it over here this
is our outer radius which is also going
to be
equal to that right over there so that's
the distance between y equals 4 and the
function that's defining our outside the
distance between y equals 4
and the function that is defining our
outside so this is essentially this
height right over here is going to be
equal to 4
minus x squared minus 2x i'm just
finding the distance or the height
between these two functions so the outer
radius is going to be 4
minus this minus x squared minus 2x
which is just 4
minus x squared
plus 2x
now what is the inner radius
inner
inner
radius what is that going to be
well that's just going to be this
distance that's just going to be the
distances between y equals 4 and y
equals x so this is going to be 4 minus
x it's just going to be 4
minus x
so if we wanted to find the area of the
face of one of these washers for a given
x it's going to be
it's going to be and we can factor out
we can factor out this pi it's going to
be pi
times the outer radius squared which is
all of this business squared so it's
going to be 4 minus x squared
plus 2x squared minus pi times the enter
is although we factored out the pi so
minus the inner radius squared so minus
4
minus x squared so this will give us
the
surface the surface area or the area of
the surface or the face of one of these
washers if we want the volume of one of
those washers we then just have to
multiply times the depth
dx we just multiply times the depth dx
and then if we want to actually find the
volume of this entire figure then we
just have to sum up all of these washers
for each of our x's so let's do that so
we're going to sum up the washers for
each of our x's and take the limit as
they approach zero but we have to make
sure we got our interval right so what
are these what are these we care about
the entire region between the points
where they intersect so let's make sure
we get our interval so to figure out our
interval we just say well when does y
equals that when does y equal x
intersect y equal x squared minus 2x so
we just have to say when does x
move just in a different color
we just have to think about when does x
equal x squared minus 2x
equal x squared minus 2x when are our
two functions equal to each other which
is equivalent to if we just subtract x
from both sides
if we just subtract x from both sides
we get when does x squared minus 3 x
equal zero we can factor out an x
on the right hand side so it's going to
be when does x times x minus 3 equals 0
well if the product is equal to 0 at
least one of these need to be equal to
0. so x could be equal to 0 or
x minus 3 is equal to 0. so x is equal
to 0 or x is equal to 3. so this is x is
0 and this right over here is x
is equal to 3. so that gives us our
interval we're going to go from x equals
0 to x equals 3 to get our volume in the
next video we'll actually evaluate this
integral